foreign
[Music]
but you're playing I mean you play for
University of Georgia you play with some
of the best somebody I mean Champ Bailey
Just Champions with all the fame right I
mean that's like and like I think he's
the number two cover of all time Dion I
mean I grew up in DC Champ Bailey is you
know what I mean I would say Dion the
greatest cover guy of all time champ is
number two that's crazy to say and he's
my one of my dearest he's as close to me
as you and has never lost the same we
are velcroed as we once were on a
college campus like how would you
describe like your college football
career I would say that it was always
full of it's so similar to my freaking
acting career
Bernie is crazy I always hear
a phenomenal strong side corner named
Robert Edwards who of course you know to
be a running back who ended up playing
with me who was drafted I think the
number top five pick in the league maybe
number two Robert Edwards tries to break
all these rules all these records that
were held by Garrison Hurst prior some
of the records Terrell Davis was there
with us as you know he went to the Hall
of Fame but Robert Edwards was moved
from strong corner to running back
because University of Georgia needed one
Heinz Ward played Wing back at times and
of course quarterback Heinz will go of
course to the Hall of Fame Richard
Seymour of course just went through Hall
of Fame but
Robert Edwards the career smells like
this to me to answer your question
Robert Edwards would always say Omari
should be starting
he should be starting guys
for him to have to say that with that
tone of voice to himself
or to his voice with that tone of voice
coming out of him and also the look on
his face he would go guys
because he was highly touted and I was
recruited by Georgia but didn't go to
Georgia so then I ended up transferring
to the University of Georgia in the
transfer now you got politics at play
because not a politics Bernard but you
didn't come here now you ought to sudden
want to come and play
so coaches do a lot of that [__] bro
and Robert Edwards Used to Say
he should be starting us and I look at
my football career as that whereas Byrne
I never was able
to get up to the place or level that I
absolutely felt I was garnered
to be able to be at
or that my efforts had garnered me being
at or whatever my skill set what was
your skill set how do you describe
yourself a football player very fast
very fast very strong can jump high if
I'm 6'1 with my speed with my ability to
jump and with my strength
I definitely think that God wanted me to
play artists as an actor even though
athletes are artists but I think I'm
there for at least five to six to seven
seasons if it's that because it's not
that and I'm vertically impaired ah
I'm not champ six foot one yeah stature
but I'm equally as ready to knock
somebody out I tease Dion I said Dion
you know you a booty tackler you would
stick that ass out to tackle yeah on
this podcast I said Dion you put that
ass out
which made of course for a nice moment
of a joke but in reality Dion knows my
gifts and life were not that of as a
football player that of a tackler he
also is probably equal to Bo Jackson one
of the top five athletes that God has
ever made in the last 100 years let's
throw Jim Thorp in sure you know if you
count what you and I do
as an actor then let's throw Paul
Robeson in this phenomenal actor meets
athlete of you know high level but when
you think about the level of what it
takes to be a great corner my favorite
overall obviously Dion is special
obviously Ronnie lot is special but my
favorite overall
when I say his name it will definitely
it will also ring true for you to think
about how I saw myself as a cornerback
running back in high school but more as
a corner and it's of course not Charles
Woodson who's a different but Rod
Woodson from the Steelers because as you
know burn Rod would go from free safety
on one week to cover corn on another
week to not only strong corner but cover
Corner covering your flanker and then he
turned the strong safety which is damn
near miniature linebacker well depending
on the game burn they put me at five
foot nine and a half five ten they would
put me at strong safety at the time 198
to 205 pounds wow but really built more
like a cover Corner wow and not just a
strong Corner more of a cover corner
right but then I go to strong safety
never play free safety but I kind of was
moved all around the defensive backfield
so I look at Charles Woodson I mean Rod
Woods excuse me and I think a lot of
what I saw myself as was him he always
was all over the place
he played for Pittsburgh strong safety
yep Ronnie Lott free safety yep Dion
cover Corner took off half of the field
of course Chan Bailey cover Corner Daryl
green another guy from your world to me
top five defensive back of all time at
five foot eight yeah Daryl green cover
corner
still a 4340 during an era where nobody
was running a 4340. but but you're up
there I mean these are all I mean you're
up there are the most my ability was way
high and I think Champion Ron his
brother think the same thing
they always see me as a very talented
defensive back
I think the guys at Furman University
where I transferred from to go to
Georgia Furman played against Marshall
Marshall had of course the second
greatest receiver of all time that being
Randy Moss and then Coach Don and from
Marshall came to Georgia as you know to
coach after Ray Goff left so I had I had
ironically Randy Moss's coach come to
Georgia could you be doing what you're
doing now if you didn't play football
no welcome
because the pain of not getting to that
level that I really really wanted to get
to as a football player I've inserted or
injected in this acting [__] when did
that decision come like when did that
when did you know okay I'm going to put
it towards acting it was immediate
I was probably
four months away from it three months
removed from it and walked on a 3.5
kilometer age walk in Atlanta with Ma
and I remember turning to her and saying
I'm gonna go to New York I'm gonna
pursue acting wow unapologetically I'm
going to New York I am very afraid that
pops won't be down with that why because
I think he thinks I still got football
left in me because I carry that
mentality so burn even if I physically
wasn't as gifted as as Champ Bailey
which I am nowhere as gifted as him I'm
definitely as gifted as some of the DBS
in the league Champ's another level that
was a gift for him but champions of you
and I in the sense that he's aware that
his purpose was so much bigger than that
okay so once you make that choice and
you say okay I'm gonna I'm gonna switch
this and this is going to be my focus I
went and talked to Pops about three
weeks later after Mom said give him a
shot
and as soon as I talked to him he was
watching an old western and I remember
walking up to his room and talking to
him and he said yeah when you want to go
it was pretty amazing to me because I
did not expect that and I remember my
mom saying give him a shot the people I
was playing with didn't become the best
in the in in the world Hall of Fame
you're right there and you said hey I'm
going to start this other thing and I'm
starting as you and I both know when you
starred in this thing you start below
the basement I mean there's most likely
it's not gonna work out for three men
Terrell Davis Travis Stroud Robert
Edwards not champ not Ron
not Heinz three men Travis shroud
who played for a little bit Robert
Edwards who tore his knee in the rookie
All-Star game on the sand in Hawaii oh
[__] he was up for the SP player
comeback story of the year when Dolphins
took him but he was never the same
Robert Edwards was probably the I think
he was the second or third pick overall
we should somebody should Google that
when did Robert Edwards get drafted we
should Google that Robert Edwards
Terrell Davis
and Travis Stroud burned when I would do
those around the campus University of
Georgia College Town Athens Georgia as
you know when I would do those readings
The Poetry readings on set or when I
started that last year doing theater and
introduced first and foremost was August
Wilson the playwright and I found home
like I did with you when I saw a piano
lesson and I saw fences I was gone
something happened inside of you you
said this is what I'm put on this side
they came to the place or they heard the
poetry reading they're not crazy and
burned when they heard it and watched
the plays those three in particular said
if this football [__] don't work out and
you can fill in the blank
burn I probably am never on an interview
been able to say those three names
when Travis Stroud Robert Edwards and
Terrell Davis who as you all know John
Elway doesn't have any rings without
Terrell Davis in the backfield those
three said
[__] yeah
and burn maybe and it might have been
innate or subconscious in the sense that
while walking on an age walk with Mom
dude what did they see you do oh I was I
would spit poetry they didn't know how
to articulate it yeah yeah they would
ask me oftentimes when you said poetry
was it was it was it the words was it
the delivery was it the whole thing was
maybe the passion maybe the passion
where was that coming from I think
that's your point about like maybe a
football player has never granted the
opportunity first and foremost we know
this to be the case if Kaepernick is
talking about the fact that the Football
League versus the other professional
leagues come off as a slave system
burn thought I can speak to that
and Roger Goodell asked me to come to
the Super Bowl about four Super Bowls
ago when champ went in yeah it seems
like pre-covered about four Christmas
ago four Super Bowls ago sorry and I did
go to the Super Bowl and Roger asked us
to be in the thing and a lot of times
NFL will want me to be a part because
they know I'm connected to the NFL and
they know that they need to restructure
their branding of the NFL and and they
also need mentors in the NFL so I've
taken on individual mentorship from
saquan from to Emmanuel Sanders to to
Odell Beckham who thinks a lot like you
and I he'll say [__] like oh I got so
much [__] at me I just gotta figure out
how to get it all out I'm like I hear
you so burn is probably that last
comment that the the latter that would
have come from an Odell who thinks like
that
how do you get it all out say Quan first
time I'm around say Quan supposed to be
one of the greatest running backs ever
coming out of college right you know
what saquan came out of Penn State
stating when he came became a giant when
we were around each other night one
saquan said but what's my purpose though
oh why am I on this Earth I said damn
this dude is deep
burn it doesn't mean that the league
doesn't have other sequans they don't
he's special but what it also doesn't
mean is that it doesn't mean that even
when you go to a league
that you're set up for someone to see
you as special there's nothing greater
as you know women can say all day oh my
God John berthal so sexy such a
beautiful guy burning a Mario not raised
to hear that Bruno Mario raised to see
these five men say I rock with you I
[__] with you that's how we're raised
yeah so football made sense for me
because the other sports it's not as
many people call teammate to [__] with
you so part of my mentality is not only
raised with all boys shiny was the Lone
sister like you're raising your boy's
got a lone sister but also football
afforded me to most brothers that was a
native natural for me that felt
comfortable and so in reality man I
think Terrell and Travis and Robert were
about yo I don't know how to articulate
it but I'm affected by what you're doing
though I saw that it was real I'm
affected yeah so may and I didn't really
they might have been my first audience
as an actor wow like whatever that is oh
do that [__] I don't know if you can
affect as many people running up and
down the football field it did so much
for me bro
[Music]
I'm gonna get a workout in a little bit
with my man Eric Linden stunt
coordinator from The Punisher he's
coming all the way up because we're
about to get after it and when that's
done he asked me in the car are you
gonna have my shake ready and I know
what that means am I gonna have my son
Warrior Shake they've got the active
protein but they also have this collagen
protein which is amazing they also have
uh the warrior blend which is a little
bit lighter if you're trying to cut and
uh I believe in it I believe in that
some Warrior stuff go to
www.sunwarrior.com
real ones for 15 off I appreciate y'all
foreign
[Music]